احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه كالعاده نبدا بابرز العناوين
يعتبر الصراع في السودان خيانه للشعب
ويحذر المتحاربين اما وقف القتال او
مواجهه العقوبات
تجدد الاشتباكات العنيفه ودوي القذائف وسط
الخرطوم ومنطقه بحري ومحيط القصر الرئاسي
في اخبارنا ايضا
رغم الاستهداف المزمع للكرملين وتعثر
عمليتها في اوكرانيا واشنطن تستبعد لجوء
روسيا للنووي
ازمه جديده وزير داخليه فرنسا يتهم ميلوني
بالفشل وروما تطلب توضيحا وتلغي زياره
لوزير خارجيتها
اهلا بكم ما اصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قرارا بتوسيع سلطات امريكا للرد على
العنف في السودان بما يشمل فرد عقوبات على
المسؤولين عن تهديد السلام وتقويد
الانتقال الديمقراطي والعنف ضد المدنيين
وانتهاك حقوق الانسان في السودان واعرب
بايدن عن التزام الولايات المتحده بدعم
تطلعات الشعب السوداني في مستقبل يسوده
السلام وبتلبيه المطالب الانسانيه في
السودان عندما تسمح الظروف مؤكدا ضروره
انهاء النزاع فورا لان الشعب السوداني
متمسك بالديمقراطيه ويرفض الصراع على
السلطه على حد وصفه واضاف الرئيس الامريكي
ان العنف الجاري في السودان ماساه وخيانه
لمطالب الشعب وانه ينضم الى دعوات الشعب
السوداني لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل دائم
[موسيقى]
قالت مديره المخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيهنز ان الصراع بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع سيطول على الارجح
واضافت في احاطه امام لجنه القوات المسلحه
في مجلس الشيوخ انا الطرفين نزاع في
السودان يعتقدان بانهما قادران على تحقيق
الانتصار عسكريا وانه لا توجد حوافز تذكر
الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات حتى الان كما
حضرت هانز من ان اي دعم خارجي لطرفين نزاع
في السودان سيفاقم الازمه ويزيد من
احتمالات انتشار التحديات الامنيه في
المنطقه
في اول تعليق رسمي للحكومه الاثيوبيه
بخصوص الوسطات الدوليه لانهاء الصراع في
السودان قبل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه ان بلاده تدعم جهود وساطه الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه الايجاد
وان الجهود الاحاديه الاخرى ستؤذن من
الوضع في السودان الوضع الحالي في السودان
ستكون له تاثيرات سلبيه علينا نتابع الوضع
السوداني بقلق بالغ ونؤكد تاييدنا دور
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه
ايجاد في الوساطه بين اطراف الصراع
السوداني ونؤمن بان الحوار هو الحل الوحيد
للازمه
مع استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع منذ الصباح والتي وصفت بالاعنف منذ
بدء الصراع افاد مراسل العربيه بان الجيش
السيطره على منطقه كوبر والسلاح الاشاره
في الخرطوم بحري بينما تقوم قوات الجيش
بتمشيط منطقه كوبر بعد السيطره عليها هذا
واظهرت الصور استهدفا جويا لتمركزات الدعم
السريع في محيط القصر الجمهوري والقياده
العامه في الخرطومات في هذه الاثناء لا
تزال اوضاع الانسانيه والطبيه في تفاقم
مستمر فبينما اعلنت وزاره الصحه ان 70% من
المستشفيات باتت خارج الخدمه لجا سودانيون
للفرار من الاقتتال الدائر وسط مخاوف من
ارتفاع موجه النزوح لارقام قياسيه
[موسيقى]
نشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا للمركبات
وللاسلحه التابعه للدعم السريع بعد
اشتباكات الاخيره في محيط السلاح الاشاره
بالعاصمه السودانيه خرطوم
[موسيقى]
لم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخلق الهدنه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها اتهم
بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن قصفا
عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سريانها اليوم بيان الدعم السريع
اكد ان القصف الذي شنه الجيش بالمدافع
والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف والقوانين
الدوليه في المقابل اكد الجيش ان قوات
الدعم السريعه حاولت الهجوم على قياده
منطقه بحر العسكريه مضيفا ان قواته دمرت
عددا من العربات القتاليه التابعه للدعم
السريع واستلمت 15 عربات بل خمس عربات تم
تركها في ميدان المعركه
حضر والي ولايه شمال دارفور من وقوع كارثه
انسانيه بمخيمات النازحين بعد ان قامت
المنظمات الامميه العامله في المجال
الانساني باجلاء موظفيها بسبب تدهور الوضع
الامني وقال ان الوضع الانساني في الولايه
ينذر بكارثه حقيقيه قبل ان يعرب عن قلق
حكومته تجاه التطورات الحاصله على الصعيد
الامني اكدوالي ولايه شمال دارفور بان هدف
الولايه الاستراتيجي هو المحافظه على وقف
اطلاق النار الذي توصل اليه الطرفان
بواسطه لجنه الحكماء مؤخرا
هذا ويعيش العاملون في محطات توليد
الكهرباء في مدينه نيالا جنوب دارفور
اوضاعا صعبه مع استمرار المواجهات
تمت يعني بناء على المبادره واخواننا دليل
في الكهرباء واخواننا الاتراك واخواننا
السائقين اللواري اللي بيحملوا حقيقه
الوقود من بورسودان لنيال يعني هل جينا
فقدناهم والان احنا في مسقعه انه كيف يفتح
الطريق عشان كل الناس
يمينك الكميه من الشكاوى يعني تعرضوا يمكن
ويتعرضوا لكثير من الحاجات مثل هذا
المشاكل اكيد يعني كل ذل نصيبه من الشيل
حصل له يعني ولذلك يحتسبوا لله لكن خلاص
الناس قادرين انه يقفوا معاهم لحد ما يرجع
باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى فاننا اظن في
الله كبير ونعمل في علم السودان كلها يعني
باذن الله سبحانه ظلم مبادرات تتكاثر
عليها حتى الناس كلهم توقف صوت الصلاح
وتحتكمل لصوت الاكل السودان محتاج الان
للحظه السودان يعني تع رضنا لحاله والله
بتجي صعبه صعبه بكل صعوبه يعني ست ايام
مرت علينا قبل كذا ما حصلت علينا سته ايام
نهب ودق وسلب وبفضل الاله وبحمد الله ومن
بعده لاخواننا في الدعم السريع والله هم
يعني انقذونا دعمونا ماديا ومع نبيا
من اقليم دارفور ينضم اليها الصحفي صالح
ابو علامه صالح اهلا بك معنا كيف يبدو
الوضع اليوم في دارفور اولا لنتحدث عن
الوضع الامني
نعمل الوضع الامني في اقليم دارفور حتى
الان هنالك هدوء وهذا الهدوء
بفضل المبادرات التي ابتكرها المجتمع
المحلي هنا في اقليم دارفور ففي كل ولايه
هنالك مبادره مجتمعيه مكونه من الشباب
والقيادات الاهليه بهدف احتواء الموقف كما
ان هنالك جهود شبابيه وجهود مجتمعيه
لتامين الاحياء لتامين
المواقع داخل الاحياء في الليل وفي النهار
ايضا عبر المتاريس وعبر حفر الخنادق حتى
وان هنالك احاديث عن بان الشباب في الليل
يحملون السلاح وهذا الامر ايضا تحدثوا
الينا بعض من الشخصيه المجتمع بان عمليه
تسليح الشباب في الاحياء هو احد الامور
الخطيره المرفوضه في هذه الفتره ولكن في ظ
انعدام الامن وفي ظل غياب الدور الرسمي كل
شيء وارث هنا
لم تعد اعرف لم تعد الشرطه مثلا الى هذه
المناطق حتى يستتب الامن
الشرطه فقط متمركزه في بعض مدن السودان
بعض مدن دارفور في الاسواق مثلا في جنوب
دارفور الشرطه في السوق
موجوده وفي بعض المواقع الاستراتيجيه لكن
في الاحياء ومداخل الاحياء لا توجد شرطه
هنالك عمليات نهب كبيره تتم في الاحياء
الشرطه غير غادره على ملاحقه العمليه
العمليات هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين يقولون
للسرقه هل هم ينتمون الى تنظيمات معينه
الى جهات معينه ام يقومون بذلك بشكل فردي
عندما بدا الصراع في دارفور بدات المعارك
في دارفور بين الجيش والدعم السريع تدخل
طرف اخر هنا معتاديه لجرائم المتفلتين
كثيرا ما نسمع بهذا الوصف معتاديه لاجرام
هم يقومون بعمليات السلب والنهب هنالك
حديث
لولي شمال دارفور قال بان عمليات النهب
والسلب اصبحت كثيره في الولايه خاصه في
الطرقات بسبب
اطلاق سراح معتاديه لجرائم في السجون
الايام الماضيه اذا نحن ندخل في معادله
اخرى ايضا
بالسلب والنهب بعد اطلاق سراحه عدد من
السجناء في بعض سجون الولايه ايضا فرغم من
عمليه النهب والسلب هنالك سلاح منتشر
هنالك اجرام كبير هنالك عمليات سلب
للسيارات سلب للبنوك سلب ايضا
للمحلات التجاريه
هذه العمليه لا تتوقف اليوم الا
الجنينه بعد التوقيع الوثيقه الان هنالك
هدوء في الجنينه بعض الخروقات التي
رصدناها مثل اطلاق الرصاص وغيرها ولكن
لجنه الوساطه تعمل على اخماد كل نار تجعل
في الجنينه هنالك قوه من الاحتياط المركزي
اليوم في سوق الجنينه بهدف وقف عمليات
السرقه التي تستمر حتى نهار اليوم مستمر
عمليات السرقه وعمليه النهب لسوق مدينه
الجنينه الوضع الانساني في مدينه الجنينه
ما زال متفاهم ما زالت الكهرباء اكثر من
عشره ايام والجنينه بدون كهرباء وايضا
بدون ما بعض الاحياء اجتهد الشباب واجتهدت
القيادات الاهليه في تشغيل المراكز مثل
المركز اردمت وايضا مياه 13 وبعض الاحياء
عادت اليه المياه لكن معظم احياء مدينه
الجني بلا ماء وبلا كهرباء حتى هذه اللحظه
هنالك انعدام كبير للدواء في مدينه
الجنينه بعد نهب المخازن وايضا بعد تدمير
المستشفى في مدينه الجنين شكرا لك من
اقليم دارفور الصحفي صلاح صالح ابو علامه
اما الان الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي عمار
ابو شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا الوضع اليوم
في الخرطوم خاصه بانه يعتبر من اكثر
الايام كانت الاشتباكات فيه قويه منذ
بدايه هذا الصراع
نعم هذه الاشتباكات كانت قويه جدا منذ
الصباح الباكر وحتى دهار اليوم وقبل دقائق
من الان كان هنالك تحليق للطيران الحربي
وما زلنا نستمع
تحلق من ثم تعقبها الطائرات المقاتله عدد
من المضادات الارضيه الان ترد على طائرات
الاستطلاع وكان هذا طوال دقائق الماده
الماضيه والان تجددت من جديد الوضع
الميداني بحسب مصادر كثيره جدا تحدثنا
اليها اشارت الى شكل واضح بان عمليات
اشتباك كانت تجري قبل ربما ساعه من الان
في محيط القصر الرئاسي وفي محيط القياده
العامه
للجيش وايضا كذلك الاشتباكات التي دارت من
خلال صباح اليوم وحتى منتصف الظهيره في
منطقه مدينه بحري سلاح الاشاره واستطاع
الجيش فيها ان يرد او يتصدى لعدد من قوات
الدعم السريعه التي حاولت التوغل والدخول
لتلك المنطقه ايضا مصادر تحدثت الينا ومن
خلال معلومات وردت بان الاشتباكات ربما
توسعت الى منطقه شرق النيل حيث كان
للطيران الحربي عدد من الغارات الجويه على
المناطق وربما ارتكازات لقوات الدعم
السريعه قبل دقائق كنا نشاهد عدد من
القوات للدعم السريع تتحرك في منطقه شرق
الخرطوم وشاهدنا ايضا كذلك عدد من
الارتكازات لقوات الدعم السريع ما زالت
موجوده في منطقه شرق الخرطوم وهذه المنطقه
ايضا هي تشكل ربما بعد استراتيجي لقوات
الدعم السريع باعتبار انها تطول على
المنطقه الشماليه والمحازيه لمدينه بحري
هذا هو الوضع الان في العاصمه الخرطوم
وعدد من المناطق المجاوره لها بالنسبه
ايضا الوضع فيها كما كان اليوم في خرطوم
بحري
نعم اندرمان كانت فيها عدد من الاشتباكات
منذ الصباح حيث شكل طيران الجو المقاتل
فيها عدد من الطلعات واستهدف فيها عدد من
المقرات بحسب المصادر التي تحدثنا اليها
انتشار القوات الدعم السريع في منطقه ام
درمان القديمه يشكل ايضا حزام ما بين شمال
المدينه وجنوب المدينه ويفصل هذه المدينه
الى نصفين باعتبار ان المنطقه الجنوبيه
توجد بها قوات للدعم السريع في معسكر
الصالحه هذه المنطقه ايضا تتمركز فيها
قوات الدعم السريع وتشكل من خلالها طوق
على المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه وهذه
الاشتباكات دارت ولكن لم تكن بتلك الكثافه
التي كانت في مدينه بحري والتي ربما تستمر
في محيط القصر الرئاسي وفي محيط قياده
الجيش عمار يمكن القول بانه
الامور والتصعيد اليوم كانه لا هدنه
نعم لا وجود لحاله الهدنه في العاصمه
الخرطوم وفي المناطق التي دارت فيها
الاشتباكات وهذا واضحا من خلال هذه
العمليات الكثيره والمكثفه سواء لطيران
الجو او حتى للعمليات والتحركات لقوات
الدعم السريعه على الارض كلا الجانبين ما
زالا يؤمنان بان احدهما يستطيع الانتصار
على الاخر وهذا ربما يلغي فرضيه الالتزام
بالهدنه وان العمليات العسكريه ما زالت
دائره في عدد من المناطق وهذا ايضا يشير
وبالنسبه كبيره لنا عمليه الحسم العسكري
ربما تمضي بشكل كبير وهذا ايضا يدل من
خلال تصريحات عدد من القاده العسكريين
الخاصه من جانب القوات المسلحه باعتبار ان
عمليه الحسم العسكري هي الاولويه وعمليات
التمشيط ما زالت مستمره في عدد المناطق
شاهدنا هل هناك هل هناك من جهود بالمسار
السياسي ام ايضا توقف المسار السياسي في
ظل هذا التصعيد
نعم المسار السياسي ربما توقف نوعا ما
ولكن بالامس كانت هنالك عدد من التحركات
ربما السياسيه وحتى الناطق الرسمي باسم
العمليه السياسيه تحدث في ذلك هنالك اشاره
اخرى وهي تحرك عدد من القواعد الشعبيه
الخاصه بلجان المقاومه في عدد من المناطق
خارج الولايه الخرطوم وكانت هنالك وقفات
احتجاجيه في مدينه ود مدني وايضا في منطقه
الدويم بالنيل الابيض وهذه الوقفات ربما
اشارته بشكل واضح الى ضروره وقف الحرب
ايضا في جانب اخر من ولايه البحر الاحمر
كانت هنالك عدد من المسيرات التي دعت الى
خروج فولكر المبعوث الاممي وطالبت ايضا
كذلك
بضروره انتصار الجيش ونصره الجيش وهذه
ربما التحركات الشعبيه تاتي بالتزامن مع
جهود حثيثه تحاول من خلالها الدول الفاعله
في الاقليم وحتى الدول التي تحدثت عن
ضروره ايجال او ايجاد حل سلمي لي
عمليه تفاوض ومن ثم المضي قدما في ايجاد
حل للمتقاتلين على ارض الواقع
الممثلين بالايام الماضيه كان هناك حديث
بانه الطرفان لديهم ممثلون سيذهبون الى
دوله معينه للبدء بهذا التفاوض هل هناك اي
معلومات حول ذلك هل هذا الامر مازال واردا
يعني كلا طرفين لم يتحدثا بشكل واضح عن
تسميه اسامي بعينها للمشاركه في عمليه
التفاوض ولكن هنالك اخبار كثيره رشحت وعدد
من التصريحات لعدد من المسؤولين الفاعلين
في الاقليم اتحدث عن امكانيه ان يجلس
ممثلين للطرفين في دوله يراها من الممكن
ان يتم فيها عمليه التفاوض وحتى حديث وزير
خارجيه جنوب السودان وحديث ممثل البرهان
في القاهره اشاره الى ان عمليه التفاوض
ربما لشكل انساني ولربما ان تمضي الى عدد
من المسارات ولكن ليس بعمليه تفاوض ما بين
القائدين على ارض الواقع حتى الان لم يصدر
بيان رسمي او تسميه رسميه من الطرفين
لممثلين لهما اذا ما تمت عمليه التفاوض
ربما هذا يكن في الساعات القادمه او
بطبيعه متغيرات الحال على ارض الميدان ومن
يستطيع ان يكسب مزيد من النقاط على ارض
الميدان شكرا لك الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه كنت
معي من الخرطوم
كشف رئيس لجنه السياسات في حزب الامه
القوميه السوداني امام الحلو للعربيه ان
حزب الامه طرح مبادره لتشكيل لجنه مشتركه
بين طرفين نزاع لتحديد اليه وقف الحرب
مؤكدا ان الحزب يعمل على توحيد موقف القوى
السياسيه لوقف اطلاق النار نحن في حزب
الامه منذ اليوم الاول طرحنا
مبادره طرفين النزاع
وطرف ثالث من الشخصيات القوميه للبحث في
وقف القتال وكيفيه
اليات تنفيذ هذا الوقف نحن الان في عزومه
نعمل على ذلك كل قوه السياسيه والمدنيه
الان نعمل على توحيده في موقف واحد محدد
في وقت هذا الصباع والان يعني اطروحات
كثيره مبادرات ان شاء الله انها تتجمع في
السرعه اللازمه
قالت الامم المتحده انها تحتاج الى 445
مليون دولار لمساعدته 860 الف شخص قد
يفرون حتى اكتوبر القادم من القتال الدامي
في السودان وقالت مفوضيه الامم المتحده
الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين انه من المتوقع ان
تستقبل مصر وجنوب السودان الحصه الاكبر من
تدفقات اللاجئين بسبب الحرب في السودان
واضافت ان هذا النداء موجه الى الدول
المانحه
اما في اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء رصدت
كاميرا العربيه اللحظات الاولى لوصول
سفينه الاجلاء الامريكيه الثانيه القادمه
من ميناء بورسودان الى ميناء جده وعلى
متنها 222 شخصا من جنسيه مختلفه بينهم
امريكيون وصلت للتو الان السفينه
الامريكيه برونسويك الى ميناء الجده
الاسلامي وهي تقف على رصيف رقم سبعه
واربعين وهي من ضمن السفن العسكريه
الحربيه او كذلك التجاريه الاجنبيه التي
تقوم باجلاء رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه
ولعلها في مقدمه هذه الجنسيات تحديدا على
هذه السفينه هم رعايا من امريكا وكذلك
جنسيات اخرى طبعا هذه السفينه هي هي ثاني
سفن برونس ويك الامريكيه العسكريه التي
تقف على هذا الرصيف تحديدا عدد الرعايه
على هذه السفينه تحديدا هم
2022 من جنسيات مختلفه ولكن حتى الان لم
تصلنا من المسؤولين في السفاره الامريكيه
عدد الجنسيات تحديدا لهذه السفينه طبعا
هناك الجهات الامنيه والعسكريه في
السعوديه متواجده وكذلك الصحه للتابعه
للسعوديه او وزاره الصحه السعوديه ايضا
تتواجد لم تردنا ايضا حتى الان افاده
كامله ووافيه من قبل السفاره
الامريكيه اذا ما كانت هناك اصابات سواء
على متن هذه السفينه او ايضا حالات طارئه
صحيا
وهذا الخبر العاجل على شاشه العربيه وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد لجوتيرج استمرار
مساء المملكه لاجلاء الرعايه من السودان
اذا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد للامين
العام للامم المتحده استمرار مساعي
المملكه لاجلاء الرعايه من السودان غادرت
الرحله الاخيره للمملكه المتحده من مطار
بورسودان الليله الماضيه بعد ثمانيه ايام
من عمليات الاجلاء متعدد المسارات حيث تم
اجلاء
2450 شخصا عبر مطار وادي سعيدنا وبورسودان
منذ بدء الرحلات الجويه يوم الثلاثاء
الخامس والعشرين من ابريل بينما ستقدم
المملكه المتحده خمسه ملايين جنيه
استرليني من المساعدات المنقذه لحياه
الاشخاص الفرين من العنف في السودان
في ذات السياق وصلت نيجيريا اجلاء المئات
من رعاياها الفرينه من القتال في السودان
واعادتهم الى بلادهم بعد ايام من التاخير
التي ترك العديد منهم عالقين وكانت مفوضيه
نيجيريين في الشتات قد اوضحت في وقت سابق
ان حوالي 2000 هجريه تقطعت بهم السبل منذ
بدء الاشتباكات في السودان
في لقاء مع العربيه اعرب كريستيانو
الاتحاد الاوروبي في القاهره عن قلقه من
الحرب في السودان قائلا ان هذا دائما ما
يعطي الفرصه للمتطرفين فكريا ومضيفا انه
يرى تعامل مصر بحرص على حدودها حتى لا
يكون هناك انتقال للارهابيين اليها لا
تنسوا نحن قلقون عندما تدور اشتباكات مثل
هذه وتتحول الى حرب لان هذا يعطي المساحه
دائما لذوي الافكار المتطرفه والارهابيه
اننا نرى ما تفعله مصر الان وهي تتعامل
بحرص على الحدود لتتاكد من عدم تسرب
ارهابيين من خلال حدودها مع السودان
واعتقد اننا سنناقش هذا على المستوى
الثنائي مع نظرائنا المصريين لنرى امكانيه
التعاون في هذا الموضوع
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه مالس اعلام انه
تم تسهيل عبور ما لا يقل
عن اخذ من جنسيات مختلفه عبر المنافذ
الحدوديه مع السودان بالاضافه لاستقبال
اكثر من الف لاجئ سوداني في اشاره الى
الدوله الاثيوبي لتخفيف وطئه المعاناه
الانسانيه في السودان
حتى الان تم تسهيل عبور اكثر من 4000 شخص
من 61 دوله عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان وتم السماح ل 75 رحله جويه لعبور
الاجواء الاثيوبيه لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان انطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا ما يحدث في
السودان سيكون له تاثير سلبي على اثيوبيا
ومن السودان الى تطورات في روسيا حيث شدد
المتحدث باسم الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جون كربي على ان بلاده لا تشجع او
تمكن اوكرانيا من ضرب اهداف خارج حدودها
واكد كوربي ان مزاعم روسيا بان الولايات
المتحده تقف وراء الهجوم على الكرملين
كاذبه على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
كره ثلج الازمه الاوكرانيه تكبر يوما بعد
يوم حادث المسيرتين فوق قصر الكرملين صب
الزيت اكثر فوق نيران الحرب المشتعله اصلا
موسكو وبعد اتهامها بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
صعدت اللهجه اكثر الخارجيه الروسيه توعدت
برد يكون بحجم التهديد سهام الانتقاد
الروسيه اتجهت مباشره نحو الولايات
المتحده فقرارات القيام بمثل هذه الاعمال
تتخذ في واشنطن وليس كيافا التي تنفذ يقول
الكرملين
مثل هذه القرارات وتعريف الاهداف وتعريف
الوسائل كل هذا تمليه واشنطن على
اوكرانيا نفت الاتهامات الروسيه جمله
وتفصيلا ووصفتها بالكاذبه فرسيا اختلقت
الهجوم لكونها تعلم انها خسرت الحرب
والكريم لان يستغل هذه الروايه لتحفيز
جنوده على الاستمرار في الحرب ومقدمه لعمل
عسكري شامل
اما زيلينس كيف حاول القيام بهجمه مرتده
من داخل مقر محكمه الجنايه الدوليه بل هاي
عبر المطالبه بمحاكمه الرئيس الروسي
تجب معاقبه بوتين على افعاله هنا في عاصمه
القانون الدولي حليف اوكرانيا الاتحاد
الاوروبي دعا الى عدم استخدامه هجوم
الكريم ذريعه لتصعيد الحرب ويكو ندع روسيا
الى عدم استخدام هذا الهجوم المزعوم ذريعه
لمواصله هذا التصعيد للحرب اكبر داعم لكي
اف سياسيا وعسكريا الولايات المتحده ابدت
تشكيكها فيما يقع البيت الابيض قال انه
ينظر بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن موسكو في
وقت اشارت الامم المتحده الى انه لا يمكن
تاكيد المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني
على الكرملين بلال الوجداني العربيه
وفي ردود الافعال الدوليه المستمره اعتبرت
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كولونا ان
الهجوم على باستخدام المسيرات حادث غريب
وغامض ولا يزال بحاجه الى تفسير حيث قالت
انه ليس لديها اي معلومات محدده حول هذا
الموضوع ولا يمكنها مناقشه الروايات
المتعلقه به
بدورها اعتبرت الخارجيه الايطاليه ان اي
عمل عسكري بما فيه محاولات استهداف مبنى
الكرملين في روسيا اعتبرته امرا لا يخدم
التسويه السلميه في اوكرانيا وقالت
الخارجيه الايطاليه ان جميع الهجمات التي
تسببت بالضرر على مبنى الكريم لا يعرف
تفاصيلها حتى اللحظه وانها لا تخدم السلام
الذي يجب ان يكون في مصلحه اوكرانيا والذي
سينتج عنه استقلالها بحسب الخارجيه
الايطاليه
قالت مديره المخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيهانز انه من غير المرجح ان تستخدم
روسيا اسلحتها النوويه حتى في الوقت الذي
تتكبد فيه خسائر فادحه في الحرب باوكرانيا
واضافت هانز امام لجنه القوات المسلحه
بمجلس الشيوخ ان استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
امر غير مرجح للغايه وان هذا التقييم بل
هذا هو التقييم الحالي للوضع
من موسكو ينضم الى عبد الجواد الرشد مراس
العربيه عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا كيف يبدو
اليوم في موسكو بعد هذا الاستهداف بالامس
كيف تبدو الحركه ما هي الاجراءات الامنيه
اذا كانت اصبحت مشدده اكثر
مساء الخير ميسون نعم يعني حتى هذه اللحظه
قضيه المسيرات ومحاوله ضربها لمبنى هي
حديث الشارع اليوم في العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو طبعا معظم التحليلات السياسيه تتحدث
عن هذا الموضوع القنوات التلفزيونيه طبعا
تطرقت بالحديث بشكل كبير عن هذه القصه
الوضع طبعا كما هي العاده قبل ايام على
عيد النصر تشفى يشهد مركز المدينه تجديد
امن نوعا ما واقفال للساحه الحمراء ومنع
دخول الزوار اليها بالاضافه الى اغلاق بعض
الشوارع هنا موسكو تزذب نحو طبعا يعني
التدريب والتدريب عرض هذا العرض العسكري
في الساحه الحمراء في اوقات من يعني
الليالي التي تسبق عيد النصر طبعا ميسون
لا يمكن اخفاء حقيقه القلق لدى الجميع او
لدى المواطن الروسي بما يخص ما وصلت اليه
المسيرات خاصه انها طبعا وصلت الى العمق
الروسي الى مركز القلب العاصمه موسكو لكن
حتى هذه اللحظه الوضع ما يزال طبعا مستقر
بنوعا ما خاصه مع التصريحات الروسيه وذهاب
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اليوم الى
مبنى وعقد اجتماع مع وزير الاقتصاد الروسي
في ذلك المبنى الاجتماعي طبعا كان مطول
وهو بحضور شخصي ايضا ميسون يعني التحليلات
السياسيه في البلاد ما زالت تطالب برد
يعني صريح ورد قاسي على ما قام به الغرب
كما تسميه موسكو حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت
موسكو تحمل واشنطن بالشكل الاول مسؤوليه
ما حدث وان كيف هي منفذ لامر واشنطن ولا
يمكن للاخيره القيام بهذا الفعل دون طلب
من الولايات المتحده فعل مثل هذه الخطوه
او الاقدام عليها فاتابع معك عبد الجواد
ولكن نذكر ببعض الاخبار العجله الخاصه
بالسودان مبعوث البرهان من اديس ابابا من
حيث يقول الوضع على الارض مستقر والجي ش
يسيطر على مواقع الدعم السريع ايضا مبعوث
البرهان يقول نواجه تمردا وليس طرفا يمكن
التفاوض معه
وبانهم يقبلون بالهدنه لاغراض انسانيه كما
يرفضون الوسطات مع الدعم السريع اعود اليك
عبد الجواد هل هناك من اي مواقف او
تصريحات جديده رسميه تجاه هذا الحادث
بالامس واتجاهه ايضا ما ذكره اليوم
ميسون يعني لعلى ابرز التصريحات الروسيه
تكمن في مقالته وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
بانه لدى موسكو اليوم الحق في الرد في
الوقت الذي تراه مناسبا والطريقه التي
تراها مناسبا طبعا هذه الطريقه تطرق لها
بيان وزاره الخارجيه وتحدث بانه سياخذ
بعين الاعتبار التهديدات الامنيه
وقدرتها على الوصول طبعا لمراكز القياده
في الحكومه الروسيه ايضا طبعا ميسون لابد
من ذكر بان مجلس الدوما الروسي يستمر في
تصريحته ويطالب طبعا بادخال اسلحه جديده
في الصراع في الاراضي الاوكرانيه وضرب
مراكز القياده في الحكومه الاوكرانيه لذلك
طبعا نلاحظ بان مجلس الامن الروسي على
لسان يعني سكرتيره والرئيس السابق للبلاد
المتري يتحدث عن ضروره القيام بخطوات طبعا
جاده يمكنها الوصول للخطوط الحمراء وهي
ضرب مقر زيلينسكي او غير ذلك لذلك طبعا
ميسون الوضع يعني غير عادي لكنه مستقر
نوعا ما هذه التصريحات وانت تتحدث معي عبد
الجواد ايضا انهاء التحقيق ميسون ساعود
اليك بموضوع التحقيق الان خبر عاجل ايضا
مسؤول بالقرم يقول الدفاعات الروسيه اسقطت
مسيره قربه قاعده عسكريه جويه اذا مسؤول
بالقرب يتحدث عن ان الدفاعات الروسيه
اسقطت مسيره قرب قاعده عسكريه جويه عبد
الجواد يبدو بانه الحرب ايضا انتقلت الى
الى مرحله جديده ويبدو بانه المسيرات هي
ستكون متصدره المشهد
صحيح ميسون يعني الجميع ينتظر موجه جديده
ان صحها التعبير تشبه الموجه التي طبعا
انطلقت مع بدايه العمليه العسكريه لكن
الفاصل الوحيد والشيء المختلف فيها اليوم
هو قضيه المسيرات ليست هي المسيره الاولى
ولن تكون الاخيره كما يرى السياسيين
والعسكريين في البلاد التي تصل والتي
تحدثت عنها الان لذلك طبعا انظمه الدفاع
الجوي هي منتشره نوعا ما في كافه المكان
في كافه الاماكن ان كانت في العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو على الشريط المتخن للاراضي
الاوكرانيه او في شبه جزيره القرم او في
دنيس او في مناطق اخرى او يعني منطقه شبه
جزيره القرم والقواعد العسكريه فيها طبعا
تشهد سقوط العديد من الطائرات من دون طيار
واليوم طبعا في مناطق مختلفه في روسيا
وصلت هذه الطائرات طبعا لم يتم الحديث
بشكل مفصل عما كانت تحميله ان كانت تحمل
عبوات متفجره او غير ذلك لكن طبعا يدور
الحديث عن
اسقاط العديد منها في مناطق مختلفه لذلك
طبعا ميسون الوضع في الداخل اليوم ينتظر
موجه جديده قد نلاحظها خلال الايام
القادمه قد نلاحظ عرض لسلاح جديد في يوم
النصر في العرض العسكري في الساحه الحمراء
او قد نلاحظ طبعا ضربات جديده كما يتحدث
عنها مجلس ادومه الروسي ميسون شكرا لك من
موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
اكد رئيس الوزراء الهولنديه مارك روتي على
ان بلاده تعمل مع الشركاء لدراسه خيارات
مختلفه لتوريد مقاتلات اف 16 لاوكرانيا
ونوه روتي في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس
الوزراء البلجيكي في لهاي عن عدم وجود اي
محرمات في هذا الامر مشيرا الى ان بلاده
تدرس مختلف الخيارات مع شركائها مثل
بلجيكا والدنمارك حول توريد هذه المقاتلات
لاوكرانيا
في الوقت الذي لم ترجح فيه المسيرات كفه
روسيا في الحرب الا انها اسهمت في تماسك
الجيش الاوكراني وبعثرت تحصينات ثاني اقوى
جيش في العالم التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحرب لاسيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
على اعتاب كييف كانت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
اول من اقفل الباب بوجه القوات الروسيه
لتسحب ذيولها خلال ساعات وتتفرق شرقا
وجنوبا فيما الخاصره اي شبه جزيره القرم
التي زرعت الشوكه الروسيه فيها منذ تسع
سنوات تتعرض كل حين لهجمات بالمسيرات
هدفها الاولي قطع امداد المعدات والغذاء
عن موسكو واستهداف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
جيش الدرون الاوكراني الذي قلل من اضرار
التفوق الروسي حجما وقدره شمل بدايه
مسيرات تجاريه رخيصه الثمن الصينيه الصنع
دي جي اي مافيك حضرت صادراتها بكين لاحقا
على اعتبار انها للاستخدام المدني فقط لكن
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه شكلت العين
الاساسيه على اوكار الخصومه تحمل كاميرات
استطلاعيه ويمكن تسليحها بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه
موسكفا الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه
المسيرات يعيبها حجمها الكبير وبطء حركتها
وسهوله اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز الانتحاريه
فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره المتسكعه
تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في منطقه الهدف
المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند التعرف الى العدو
تطلق من مسافات بعيده ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر
حجمها اهميه هذا السلاح ادركته موسكو
سريعا فاندفعت الى ايران لشراء مسيرات
انتحاريه عمياء بدقه ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول
مره في خركيف ثم كييف واداس وميكولياف غير
ان هذه المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات الروس
واخفقت كثيرا وفق واشنطن
قالت الصين ان هناك حاجه لليقظه شديده
لمواجهه توسع الناتو شرقا في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ جاء هذا بعد بروده
التقارير تفيد بان حلف شمال الاطلسي يخطط
لانشاء مكتب في اليابان لتسهيل المشاورات
مع الحلفاء والشركاء الامنيين في المنطقه
اسيا هي مقر السلام والاستقرار وارض واعده
للتعاون والتنميه ولا ينبغي ان تصبح ساحه
معركه للمنافسه الجيو السياسيه توسع
الناتو المستمر شرقا في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ والتدخله في الشؤون
الاقليميه سيقضيان حتما على السلام
الاقليمي وسيشجعان الكتلى على مواجهه
بعضها البعض ما يعني ان على دول المنطقه
ان تكون في حاله تاهب قصوى
وفي سياق اخر قال وزير الدفاع التايواني
ان تسليمه اول طائره من اصل 66 طائره
جديده من طراز افسته عشر الامريكيه الصنع
لبلاده تاخر بسبب التعطل سلسله التوريد
من المقرر تسليم طائرات اف 16 هذا العام
لكن هذا لن يحدث بسبب تعطل سلسله التوريد
القوات المسلحه لبلدنا لديها خطط احتياطيه
لكل مشروع قيد التنفيذ خصوصا وان العديد
من عمليه الاستحواذ لا تتم بالكامل تايوان
طلبت من الولايات المتحده تعويضا نقص بما
في ذلك اعطاء الاولويه لتسليم قطع الغيار
للاسطول الحالي حاليا نعمل على تقليل
الضرر الناجم عن ذلك
من الرياض ينضم الي عبر رسوم الهامليه
الصحفي الصينيه الهام اهلا بك معنى الصين
تقول بان هناك حاجه
لليقظه الشديده لمواجهه توسع الناتو شرقا
في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ هل من
الممكن ان نفهم من هذا الكلام بان الصين
ما زالت مصره على عدم التهاون بهذا
الموضوع
كانت الموضوع بمده طويله يعني حتى في سنه
سابقه كان النسخه الاسيويه لحلف الناتو
يتضمن الى الولايات المتحده واليابان
واستراليا والهند ولكن في العامل الحالي
يعني تغيرت بشكل او بنوع ما يعني الى
الولايات المتحده واليابان وفيليبين وايضا
في الحقيقه يعني هذه النسخه نسخه الاسيويه
لحلف الناتو خطير جدا ليس فقط بالنسبه
للصين وايضا بالنسبه للدول في منطقه اسيا
الباسيفيك وخاصه في الدول في منطقه
شرق اسيا او جنوبي شرقي اسيا بما فيها
الفلبين وايضا ماليزيا وعددا من الدول في
الحقيقه يعني كما قال بعد المحللين
الولايات المتحده ترغب في التوريد الفل
او الدول الاخرى وحتى لاحظنا ان هناك
تصريحات من قبل رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه بشان
قضيه الحيوان وهذه قضيه تعتبر يعني خط
الاحمر
بنسبه للصين لذلك
بهذه النقطه اسمح لي ان اعلق عليها نعم
ايضا يتحدث الان وزير الدفاع التايواني
بانه هناك تاخير بتسليم طائرات اف 16
هل برايك هو بمحضى الصدفه هذا التاخير ام
من الممكن ان يكون رساله عن حسن نيه
الولايات المتحده تجاه الصين كيف يمكن ان
نفهم هذا التاخير
بس في الحقيقه يعني لا اعرف بالضبط ايش
الاسباب لتاخيره
توريد هذه الطائرات الحربيه الى تايوان من
قبل الشركات الامريكيه ولكن في الحقيقه في
نفس الوقت وفي الاسبوع الماضي ماضي لاحظنا
ان هناك عدد من رؤساء تنفيذيين
الشركات الاسلحه الامريكيه وخاصه يعني
الشركات الكبرى هم يجتمعون في جزيره
تايوان في المناقشه لبيع الاسلحه الى
تايوان مهما كانت من المقاتلات
الامريكيه وايضا لصواريخ لذلك يعني اذا
ترغب الولايات المتحده تعبير عن حسن نيه
للصيني فاول التوقف عن العمل الاستفزازيه
بما فيها
تقديم دعم لسلطات التايوان وخاصه لرئيسه
الحاليتين ون تسعى لعلان بشكل من الاشكال
للاستقلال تايوان في نهايه الولايات في
الحاليه بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني كما تفضلت
في البدايه النسخه الاسيويه لهلب هناك
وهذه امر خطيره بالنسبه جدا
الاشعار
النار للحرب او الاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه
من منطقه
وخاصه في بحر الصين الجنوبي لاحظنا ان
هناك
نوعا ما من الاشتباكات بين
السفن الحربيه صينيه وسوفنا الحربيه
الفلبينيه ولكن عندما نتكلم مع هذا
الموضوع يعني كان هناك جماعه من وسائل
الاعلام على السفن الحرب السفينه
الفلبينيه لذلك يعني مهما كانت هناك
التغيرات للمواقف الدبلوم
في الحقيقه يعني الصين دائما تركز على
الحفاظ على السلامه والاستقرار في منطقه
بحر الصين الجنوبي وخاصه كان هناك المبدا
المعترفه بها دوليه يعني تخلي عن الخلافات
ولتحقيق تطوير المشتركه ولتحقيق المصالح
المشتركه لذلك يعني
التصرفات الصينيه وخاصه فيما يتعلق في
التصرفات العسكريه لضمان على سيادتها
واعراضها لكن يعني هذا ليس ضد دوله معينه
مهما كانت
الولايات المتحده شكرا لك من الرياض عبر
رسوم الهاملي الصحفيه الصينيه
قاتل بل قتل الجيش الاسرائيليه اربعه
فلسطينيين صباح اليوم ثلاثه منهم في حي
الياسمينه في البلده القديمه من مدينه
نابلس والرابعه داخل بلده حواره بحجه
طعمها جنديا اسرائيليا وكان اكثر من 200
جنديا وضابط في الجيش الاسرائيلي اقتحموا
مدينه نابلس صباحا وحصروا منزلا في حي
الياسمينه وامطروه بالرصاص والقنابل
في ذروه الحركه التجاريه وحركه الطلاب
دخلت قوه خاصه من الجيش الاسرائيلي حي
الياسمين في البلده القديمه من نابلس
وحاصرت منزلا تحصن فيه عدد من المسلحين
الفلسطينيين
اشتباكات عنيفه ووابل من الرصاص
والمتفجرات القاها الجيش الاسرائيلي
باتجاه المنزل ما اوقع ثلاثه قتلى قالت
اسرائيل انهم متورطون في عمليه اطلاق
النار في الاغوار جنود الاحتلال فاتوا على
الحاره بقوات هائله من الجنود والمدرعات
حوالين البلده القديمه
والصواريخ كانت بشكل مش طبيعي يعني ما
همهم اذا كان مين جوا بالبيت ما همهم اذا
هالاطفال رايحين عالمدارس وصلنا
شهداء كان هناك تشويه فيتامين في جثتين
كانت هناك بدون راس والجثه الثالثه كانت
اصابات عده الرصاصات في الراس وصلت ثلاث
اصابات بعير ناريه في وضع متوسط الى بسيطه
في الاطراف السفليه
اطلاق نار كثيف رافق خروج الجنازات من
مستشفى رفيديا الحكومي وسط اجراءات عسكريه
وحصار مشدد على محيط مدينه نابلس تخوفا من
رد الفصائل على العمليات الاسرائيليه
اكثر من 200 جندي وضابط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي شاركوا في العمليات التي تقول
اسرائيل انها قتلت خلالها منفذي عمليه
اطلاق نار في الاغوار ادت الى مقتل ثلاث
مستوطنات بدايه الشهر الماضي من حي
الياسمين في البلده القديمه بنابلس خالد
القاسم العربيه
بينما اعلنت السلطات البريطانيه استعدادها
لحفل تتويج الملكه تشارلز ستصبح قرينته
كامله ملكه خلال الحفل حيث تنتظرها تحديات
كبيره لتكسب شعبيه بين عامه الناس
[موسيقى]
هي حب حياتي تشارلز منذ شبابه وزوجته خلال
العقدين الماضيين بعد اعتلاء تشارلز العرش
اصبحت الملكه القرينه لكنها بعيون الناس
كانت دائما المراه الاخرى كما ظلت دائما
محل مقارنه بالاميره ديانا زواجها من ولي
العهد لم يكن ضمن خطتها المستقبليه ولا
ضمن توقعاتها حتى
العالم بزواجه من كاميلا عام 2005 وكان
ثاني زواج لكليهما لم تحضر الملكه
اليزابيث حينها الزواج المدني ولكنها
باركت هذا الزواج لاحقا كما علمنا في وقت
لاحق من خلال تصريحات هاري اللاذعه ضد
العائله بانه وشقيقه ويليام توسل تشارلز
الا يتزوج كملا لكن ذلك لم يردعه حينها
ولدت عام
1947 لعائله غنيه ووالدها ضابط متقاعد من
الجيش ارتبطت بضابط في سلاح الفرسان يدعى
ان في منتصف الستينات لكنها تعرفت الى
تشارلز مطلع السبعينات ووقع في حبها منذ
اللحظه الاولى بحسب احد كتاب السيره
الذاتيه لتشارلز
تشارلز ظل قريبا من كاميلا وزوجها السابق
وكان عرابا لطفلهما الاول تزوجت تشارلز
ديانا عام
1981 ولكن ظلت كاملا جزءا من حياته
وكلفتها علاقته السريه به صورتها امام
البريطانيين الذين لطالما نظروا اليها
كمخربه لزواج تشارلز بديانا
ورغم تاكيدات تشارلز ان علاقته بكامله لم
تستانف الا بعد انهيار زواجه من ديانا الا
ان ديانا كانت تعتبر خلاف ذلك
ففي مقابلتها الشهيره عام
1995 افصحت كنا ثلاثه في هذا الزواج
طلاقك مله كان عام
1995 في حين انتهى زواج تشيلسي وديانا
رسميا عام
1996 بعد وفاه ديانا عام
1997 انسحبت كاملا من المشهد لكن تشارلز
اصر على وجود كاملا في حياته ليتزوج بعدها
في احتفاليه مدنيه صغيره في ظل الجدل حول
لقبها كملك محتدما خلال حكم الملكه
اليزابيث التي منحت كاملا لقب الملكه
القرينه قبل وفاتها بعده اشهر خلال
الاحتفال بيبيلها البلاتيني
صوره كامله قرينه للملك لا زالت مهتزه
وشخصيتها مثاره جدلا وانقسامات في الشارع
البريطاني قصر باكينج وتشارلز حاول تحسين
صوره كاميرا امام عامه الناس وكمل بذلت
جهودا حديثا للاعتراف بها في العائله لكن
بالنسبه للبريطانيين الزجاج المكسور لا
يعود كما كان ووفاه الاميره ديانا كسرت
قلوب البريطانيين الذي ينظر الكثير منهم
لكم على انها الملام في ماساه ديانا من
لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذا الخبر العاجل السفينه السعوديه امانه
تصل الى جده وعلى متنها
1762 شخصا تم اجلائهم من السودان وهذه
الصور المباشره لوصول السفينه السعوديه
امانه الى جده ونعود ونذكر بانه على متنها
1762 شخصا تم اجلائهم من السودان طبعا هذه
العمليات منذ اكثر من اسبوع من بورتسودان
الى جده
رحلات عديده وسفن عديده وصلت الى جده الى
اكثر من الى الميناء وايضا الى
المطارات في السعوديه التي اجلت العديد من
الرعايه ان كان من
الدول الغربيه او الدول العربيه
وقامت السعوديه بجهود كبيره وجباره خلال
عمليات الاجلاء حيث
هذه الرحلات بسلاسه من بورت سودان الى
القواعد الجويه او الى امينه جده
اذا نتابع سويا وصول السفينه امانه الى
جده والتي تحمل
1762 شخصا تم اجلاؤهم من السودان وكانت
سفن عديده ايضا وصلت الى هذا الميناء تحمر
على متنها الالاف من الرعايه الاجانب
والعرب
وطبعا تم تامين مسكنهم حتى وقت مغادرتهم
الى
بلادهم امنت لهم فياز محدوده طبعا حتى
يتمكنوا من الدخول الى السعوديه ومن ثم
الى مغادره
مغادرتهم الى بلادهم
الالاف من
اليمنيين والسوريين واللبنانيين
والجزائريين
والمغاربه يعني من كل الجنسيات تاكلها
وصلت الى القاعده الجويه في السعوديه واي
الى ميناء جده حيث كانت تتم عمليات
الاجلاء من بورتسودان الى جده
اذا ما زلنا نتابع وصول هذه السفينه
ودائما من خلال تغطيتنا لكل هذه الايام
لدى وصول
السفن الى جده دائما تكون كل القطاعات
موجوده عند وصول هذه السفن وخاصه
الهيئات الصحيه في حال كان هناك اي شخص
مريض او اي شخص مرهق من التعب فدائما يتم
معاينتهم ويتم الاهتمام بهم طبعا
الاليه هي بعد ما ينزلون من هذه السفن
يتوجهون طبعا الى اماكن تخليص المعاملات
والاوراق ومعظم الاحيان يكون هناك ممثلين
عن قناصل هذه الدول او بعض المنظمات ايضا
تكون متواجده ومن ثم يتم نقلهم
بالبساط الى اماكن سكنهم ومن ثم طبعا
يغادرون الى بلادهم اذا اكثر تقريبا من من
عشره الاف شخص خلال هذه العمليه عمليات
الاجلاء قد خرجت من السودان
ووصلت من بورتسودان حقيقه ووصلت الى جده
وخاصه هذا الميناء
هذه الرحله الثانيه لامانه وتقريبا نقلت
اكثر من 3000 شخص يعني هذه السفينه بالذات
نقلت اكثر من 3000 شخص ساذهب الى سلطان
الان سلطان هل تسمعني هل اصبح جاهزا سلطان
سلطان يبدو
تفضل نعم
اهلا بك اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
بالفعل وصلت الان سفينه امانه وهي الرحله
الثالثه لهذه السفينه التجاريه المدنيه
السعوديه وتحمل اعداد كبيره من الرعايه
بعد ان تم اجلائهم من ميناء بورت سوداني
لقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه او بجده وعلى
متنها الف وسبعمائه
راكبا من ثلاثا وثلاثين جنسيه تعادت
الجنسيات واختلفت من ضمنهم 81 امريكي
ونتحدث عن 19 من الجنسيه المصريه وكذلك
نتحدث عن وجود ثلاثه المان وايضا اعداد
كبيره لهؤلاء الرعايه على سبيل المثال
وجود اثنين من البرازيل وكذلك من الفلبين
واذربيجان وسريلانكا وجزر القمر وباكستان
وايضا الدنمارك والكاميرون والصومال
والسويد والسويسرا والقائمه تطول ممن تمت
اجلائهم من ميناء بورت السودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده وهذه الرحله
البحريه الثامنه عشر التي تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه من ضمنها 15 رحله
سفينه تابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
وثلاثه بهذه الرحله تكون الثامنه عشره
نتحدث عن ثلاثه رحلات مدنيه وهذه هي
الرحله الثالثه تصل الان وعلى متنها كما
ذكرنا اعداد كبيره من الرعايه
وكما هو بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
تتحدث عن اجلاء اكثر من سته الاف مواطن من
اربعه جنسيات وصلوا الى ارض السعوديه
قادمين الى قاعده الملك فيصل وكذلك عبر
ايلا قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وايضا
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي كافه الرحلات
البحريه والجويه هي قادمه من مدينه بورت
سودان من مطار بورت سودان تحديدا ومن
قاعده ومن ميناء بورتسونا نتحدث عن اعداد
كبيره من المتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه ان
تصل الس عسكريه باتاب القوات البحريه
السعوديه وعلى متنها اعداد كبيره من
الرعايه وبختلاف جنسيتهم لحظات بسيطه ويتم
انزال هذا الرام الخاص بالسفينه لبدء
انزال عملياتها اواء الرعايه بدءا كبار
السن والنساء وايضا ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
وكذلك المصابين او من هم يحتاجون للرعايه
الصحيه عاجله وبعد ذلك بقيه الركاب كما
يظهر امامكم الكاميرا الان اعداد كبيره من
الرعايه قفون على سطح هذه السفينه المدنيه
السعوديه بانتظار عمليات انزالهم الى ارقى
الفيصل مع قاتم الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
ومن ثم هنالك اسطول كبير من الحافلات تم
توفيره من قبل السلطات السعوديه سوف يتم
نقل هؤلاء الرعايه الى مقرات السكن بعد
نعم
ساعودك ولكن سنتابع هذه التغطيه مع
الزميله ليال الاختيار لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات